hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast obtaining non-invasive
readouts in early safety signals from
rated models i am christina mohammed uh
blackbirds and I'll be your moderator
for today's events we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by labyrinth and sponsored by
Byam via this silicon valley-based
technology company applying digital
technology into nvivo studies may have
developed a novel digital vivarium
platform incorporating HD video cameras
and remote sensors for 24/7 recording of
experiments along with software and
video processing algorithms to track and
extract novel metrics and readouts for
more information please visit vayam comm
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green a Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left lastly this is an educational
web seminar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process obtaining your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. Laura Chavez Laura Chaffetz has more
than 15 years of experience in nvivo
animal studies as the piece of
scientific technologies at maíam she
oversees the development of animal
models and draws upon her experiences as
a molecular and behavioral
neuroscientists to direct the
application of volumes digital metrics
to the animal models her past
experiences include work across a broad
spectrum of models including transgenic
and nutrition induce models of neuro
development disorders I will now turn it
over to dr. Chaffetz for her
presentation dr. and the floor is yours
thank you for joining me today I'll
begin by reviewing many of the
challenges inherent with using animal
models to predict efficacy and safety of
compounds during the drug development
process
I will then introduce an innovative
technology platform that biome has
developed to address these mini
challenges throughout the continuous
collection or through the continuous
collection of the physiological data
throughout the course of the study to
gain insights finally I'll demonstrate a
few of the ways that vayam is using this
platform to discover insights in
specific disease indications
the prediction of advocacy and safety of
potential therapeutics in preclinical
rodent studies is challenging the
challenges can arise from both the
applicability of animal models to the
human condition as well as in study
design and execution
obviously rodents are not humans as such
disease and injury models in rodents
ought to capture one or two of the
disease features but they do not capture
the full complexity of the disease
course for its mechanisms in the context
of drug development researchers must
carefully pick models that have both
known drug mechanisms of action that are
likely to be translatable to the human
as well as mechanisms against which
their drugs are predicted to act there
is an addition I'll add in complication
that interspecies variability between
pathways and biological systems need to
be taken into account as a few examples
interspecies variability in the immune
system between rodents and humans
complicates the assessment of
immune-mediated diseases and the
assessment of biologics in those animals
to ameliorate this problem much work has
gone into the development of mice with
human immune systems as well as in other
humanized organ systems another example
is in the assessment of drug side
effects CNS side effects account for
attrition of drugs during clinical
trials and upwards of 10 percent of the
drugs which are withdrawn from sale here
meet and colleagues took an unbiased
approach to assess whether traditional
rodent functional observational
batteries or fo bees or Arwen tests
could be could have been used to predict
these adverse events using data
collected from five pharma companies the
key takeaway messages here are that the
rodent tests were able to catch serious
side effects such as ataxia seizures
which account for a high translational
value however there was a class
side effects such as dizziness nausea
headache shown over here that the
traditional fo B and our wind batteries
weren't able to capture this is perhaps
not unsurprising given the interspecies
differences in the presentation of
nausea for example rather the author
suggests that perhaps a novel approach
such as through the continuous
monitoring of rodents may have been
better able to detect these
physiological changes that correlate
with these adverse events the second
main challenge arises around study
design and execution in order to move
the discovery of new drugs forward
faster you can think of the pharma
companies biotechs and academics around
the world of testing compounds in
parallel if you'd like obviously
reproducibility amongst all of these
various companies is a main concern and
it's not just the invivo studies it's
also the in vitro studies the extent of
this concern is evidenced by the large
number of influential papers which are
not coming out from key pharmaceutical
leaders such as Bayer and Amgen as well
as in key initiatives by NIH which cite
that upwards of 50 to 90% of the
published studies are ear reproducible
their reproducibility is often cited to
be the result of many factors including
differences in study design in execution
and analysis and this may result in
different study outcomes depending upon
the location or at the same compound
importantly the call is never to limit
science but to improve the study design
and to provide more data and the ability
to record and monitor these parameters
which may affect the study results so
one example of a lack of reproducibility
was highlighted in this paper by Steven
paren
and colleagues at the ALS Institute here
they attempted to reproduce data from
over 100 compounds that have been
published as showing positive effects in
ALS animal models they were not able to
reproduce the effects shown in the
literature in fact many of the compounds
actually showed no positive effect upon
retesting in looking at the studies it
was clear that a more careful design
identification of perhaps trans more
translationally relevant outcome
measures and better powered studies may
have improved the overall experimental
results in those initial experiments one
of the studies of elements that
researchers are unable to currently
track well is the environment so while
it's easier to keep variables constant
while testing compounds on rodents in
comparison of course to trying to track
these variables and humans and clinical
trials there's still a large number of
generally untracked factors that are
predicted to impact the overall outcomes
of a study many of these may be obvious
including the apparent smells sounds
perhaps even lighting levels in the cage
as a behavioral neuroscientists myself I
can tell you I've heard many behavioral
ist's who lament that depending upon
rack position whether it's the front or
the back or the top or the bottom an
animal may perform differently on a
specific task disruptions to circadian
rhythms due to entry of animal rooms
after hours
the timing of dosing all of these are
known sources of variability
standardizing all of these variables in
an animal study across the world is
certainly unrealistic and one may
predict that it would also lead to
stifled discovery of new drugs but what
if a scientist
could precisely track and account for
all of these study variables during data
analysis and that's where the Byam
digital platform is well-suited we
started by building a better cage
drawing upon expertise in sensors and in
the collection storage and analysis of
large quantities of data we created a
system that monitors every aspect of an
animal study continuously and
automatically the racks are designed to
monitor precise environmental conditions
at all caged positions gas sensor
modules monitored temperature and
humidity for individual cage
illumination provides uniform
environmental conditions for all animals
all environmental condition data is
piped through and stored with a study
record so if there are any abnormalities
you'll know about it video cameras are
backed by computer vision algorithms
that provide physiological data and are
able to pull out meaning we've developed
an engage scale which combined with
conventional in life measures and
biomarkers to give you a comprehensive
view on how a drug is affecting an
animal it's digital medicine for
preclinical studies and we collect
vastly more information than has ever
been possible before
we deploy these cages at scale we have
thousands of them operating today and
volumes digital vivarium in the South
Bay all the data from these experiments
are shipped to the volume cloud where it
is stored and analyzed studies are
accessed through our online research
suite where a researcher can design run
and analyze an experiment from a laptop
anywhere in the world results are
available in real time even while this
study is running to give you an idea of
what our online platform
looks like you can see a slide shot here
data is available both for individual
subjects on the subject view or across a
full study in the analytic studio on the
subject view you can explore a full
video record of the entire study by
selecting on regions of interest in the
time selector here or by exploring
specific data points by clicking on
areas of interest on motion here
breathing rate here or other very graphs
not shown here which include temperature
humidity subject observations in
addition in the analytic studio here we
see the analytic studio you can explore
data in easily downloadable graphs
complete with statistical tests or
explore the data on your own by
downloading all study data including
hourly motion breathing rate and
conventional studies our conventional
measures we've developed a number of
metrics that we use to monitor the
animals continuously two of the measures
shown here are relevant across almost
all of the disease indications and
they're basic measures of motion and
breathing rate and both are derived from
video using complex computer vision
algorithms so for example to measure
motion the direction and velocity of
motion between video frames is
calculated at defined points in the
video image all of these small dots you
see under computer vision analysis the
velocity is then used to create a
frame-by-frame summary of motion which
is read out in the activity summer
with the highest speeds reading out as
the brightest blue spots here you can
see that the brightest blue spots
correlate with the location of the mouse
we calculate the speed on every frame in
total we actually acquire 86,400 data
points per day per animal that's a lot
of data points on the individual subject
graphs we present motion which is
averaged into small time windows on the
order of minutes but for analysis we can
analyze motion in any way imaginable
including averaged by day/night or in
any time window which is appropriate for
a specific study for more information as
well as additional validation data
please see volumes website to measure
breathing rate we use points of time
when the animal is still for a larger
greater than 30 seconds after
identifying the animal you can see
outlined in the orange box on the video
frame the strength of periodic movements
that fall within rodent breathing rate
frequency bands are then plotted as
individual data points on the subject
view shown on the far right is data from
our validation study run in mice to
demonstrate that the computer vision
algorithms accurately measure breathing
rate here we took C 57 B l6j or C 3 H
mice and place them inside of a plasma
graph inside of our vayam cages we then
compared each computer vision generated
breathing point to the breathing rate
used computer vision breathing point to
the breathing rate using the platysma
graph and we found that the rates were
highly correlated with an r-square point
nine eight
on average we
at c57 vl6 jameise should a
significantly higher breathing rate at
around 180 breaths per minute versus the
hundred and thirty six breaths per
minute and t3h mice which is consistent
with the literature again please feel
free to visit our website for additional
validation data and the relevant
literature citations I now want to take
the opportunity to share case study data
collected on the biome platform from two
of our animal models including lupus and
lung injury models these models while
predictive both have limitations that
make running the model labor-intensive
and yield few in life measures against
which to assess drug efficacy let's
begin with lupus lupus is a
heterogeneous disease which manifests in
humans with a number of different
clinical signs that include renal
failure hair loss and rashes painful and
swollen joints all the way to CNS
symptoms including anxiety fatigue and
potentially cognitive dysfunction
importantly the number and extent of
these clinical symptoms varies among
individuals with lupus so not all
individuals with lupus have all of these
symptoms
there are several animal models whose
pathology mimic these many aspects of
the human disease current conventional
measures in these models focus on
assessing a subset of the clinical
symptoms in life including renal failure
as measured by proteinuria and auto
antibody production and then assess
tissue tissue histopathology at study
end
well a few labs are beginning to explore
the translational value of some of the
more CNS specific side effects these
studies are currently very labor
intensive and not
easily used processing drugs at scale in
addition to the limitations and the ease
of collecting biological insights into
some of the more complex disease states
there is the additional downside that
lupus models are very long to run
standard spontaneous genetic models such
as the mr ll P R and n zbw models can
take upwards of 10 to 20 weeks minimum
for the in life phase with additional
time at study end to conduct
histopathological assessment of the
tissues as an example here today I'm
unable to show you any histopathology
because while the study was completed
more than a month ago
we're still waiting given the length of
the study there's the added cost of
maintaining the animals and the
significant amount of compound required
to dose the animals for over ten weeks
to assess efficacy to give you an idea
in this study we used a conventional MRL
lpr model of lupus this was a
traditional prophylactic study in which
the treatment of to reference compounds
were begun prior to disease onset to
orient orient you to the study design we
ran the study in a very conventional way
looking at the timeline the animals were
brought in house at 6 weeks and we're
allowed to a Clemente acclimate until
nine weeks of time at which point here
at which point we began to dose the
cyclophosphamide one time every seven
days or with dexamethasone three times
per week we measured conventional
endpoints throughout the study including
body weight and proteinuria weekly
throughout the course of the study at
study end point we collected spleen
weights and also kid
for histopathology on top of the
standard study we overlay the vayam
platform so prior to beginning dosing we
randomized animals into treatment groups
using both motion as well as body weight
then throughout the course of the study
we continuously collect motion and
breathing rate data as we were able to
assess in the few instances where
animals were found dead the
circumstances of death by a
retrospective analysis of the videos in
all of these cases we found that the
animals died following severe and
explained convulsions here we
demonstrate the disease incidents in the
MRL lpr mouse
looks similar to the literature in our
hands the dotted lines on each of the
graphs shown here represent the start of
treatment vehicle treated mrl lpr mice
these are the grey lines why we found
that body weight increased starting
around 12 weeks of age compared to the
control which are the dark black lines
both the reference compounds
dexamethasone in blue and
cyclophosphamide in orange show less
severe body weight increases compared to
the vehicle treated mrl animals after 15
weeks of age proteinuria scores are also
significantly elevated in vehicle
treated MRO mrl mice after 4 months of
age and this is a again significantly
ameliorated by both dexamethasone and
cyclosporine at 5 months of age
looking at biometrics they show a
similar disease incidence and course
again on both graphs we represent the
time of treatment as started by the
dotted line given that this is
prophylactic dosing I'll remind you that
we do not expect animals to show signs
of disease at this stage and you can see
prior to that dotted line relatively
consistent motion and breathing rate
data at that time at that age focusing
on the graph on the left you can see
that motion decreases over time for all
groups including the dark lined controls
decreases in motion over time is
actually standard across many of the
studies that we run it by them and is
associated with aging however you can
see that the vehicle treated mice again
these are the two grey lines here showed
significantly lower levels of activity
than in either the Dex or the
cyclosporine groups that greet the blue
and the orange groups beginning at 13
weeks of age in fact we found that
motion in the cyclosporine and
dexamethasone treated groups are not
content than control mice
unlike motion breathing rate actually
increases over time in the vehicle
treated mice shown here you can see that
starting at around 14 weeks of age the
vehicle treated animals have
significantly elevated breathing rates
but again cyclophosphamide and
dexamethasone treated animals the blue
and the orange lines are no different
from the genetic wild-type controls
shown here
I now place the conventional measures of
body weight and proteinuria and next to
volumes motion and breathing rate
metrics for your comparison we find that
the via metrics of motion and breathing
rate tract disease progression similarly
to the conventional measures with one
very notable difference we find that we
begin to distinguish groups a few weeks
earlier specifically at thirteen and
fourteen weeks of age for the
volumetrics compared to the 15 to 17
weeks of age for the conventional
measures of body weight and proteinuria
this data suggests further that the mrl
LPR model of SLE of lupus that the
volume digital vivarium and volumes
metrics can be used to effectively
distinguish therapeutic efficacy of
several reference compounds volumes
platform provides insights into
physiologically relevant measures which
track disease and reflect drug efficacy
such as the motion and breathing rate
both of which provide a more holistic
overview of disease state in SLE
increased breathing mate rate may be a
reflection of pulmonary edema or acute
reversible hype hypoxemia secondary to
renal failure it could be due to
interstitial pneumonia or increased cell
infiltrates and lungs or it could be a
general immune mediated response which
has been reserved in lupus patients
although its path of physiological
relevance to disease requires further
investigation in our hands breathing
rate here does appear to be a sensitive
metric against which we can assess drug
efficacy
now we move to the lung injury model
which presents many of similar
challenges to lupus models in the
availability of easy to acquire in life
measures a number of lung injury models
have been developed to assess various
mechanisms of lung injury based on
reproducing known risk factors for acute
respiratory distress in humans a
physiologically relevant measures in
life or a more physiologically relevant
measure in life is the actual
measurement of lung function through
highly labor-intensive analysis of
respiratory function as are sometimes
measured on devices such as the
plethysmograph or researchers may choose
to focus on lung histopathology
assessment at the end of the study we
however hypothesize that the continuous
measurement of breathing rate may
provide an easily accessible measure
using the biome platform for the model
we show you today we use a paraquat
induced lung injury again to orient you
to the model here paraquat
administration leads to a loss in
pulmonary function and inflammation that
is coupled to the loss of mitochondrial
DNA integrity and eventually to the O
permanent loss of lung tissue to orient
you to this study we used Lewis rats
between 300 and 350 grams the rats were
acclimated to our facility for seven
days at which time they were
administered a single intratracheal dose
of paraquat or saline we track
conventional measures including body
weight and body temperature both before
and after lung injury on top of the
standard study we again overlaid the
vayam platform
we found the breathing rate and all rats
was very consistent therefore when we
randomized animals we based it off of
motion and body weight we then monitored
motion and breathing rate both before
and after a lung injury here we
demonstrate again the conventional body
weight and body temperature demonstrate
a robust robust induction of lung injury
body weight is plotted body weight and
body temperature is plotted as a
function of day with again the dotted
lines shown here as the day of induction
body weight was significantly as you can
see body weight prior to induction is
similar in both groups the body weight
significantly decreases two days
post-injury and the paraquat injected
animals those are the blue lines
compared to the controls in the black
but they begin to recover on days five
and six post injury body temperature is
also significantly decreased on days two
to four after injury but recovers to
normal by five to six days post-injury
now we look at biometrics here the
breathing rate and motion are plotted in
a slightly different way they're plotted
as for our averages such that you can
see circadian changes in activity and
breathing rates if you focus first on
the motion graph to the right you can
see that night time is represented as
the dark bands where my arrow is and
that the time of a lung injury is again
marked as this faint dotted line shown
here you can see a clear pattern of day
and nighttime activity representing the
circadian rhythms prior to injury about
halfway through the first evening after
injury around 16 hours here there is a
significant drop in activity in the
paraquat rounds which persists for
several days this drop begins to recover
although not fully until days 5 & 6 post
injury the breathing rate shows a much
more persistent effect as early as 12
hours post injury breathing rate was
significantly elevated by as much as 2
times the baseline rate this effect
persists throughout the 6 days that the
animals were followed with no
amelioration the effect here was
actually so significant the power
analysis using this data suggests that
we would only have required 2 to 3
animals to to achieve highly
statistically significant results
again comparing the conventional body
weight and body temperature measures to
conventional measures we note the
following first that the pattern of
motion changes tracks quite similarly
with body weight and body temperature
providing additional support for
conventional measures and we find that
motion and body weight are both more
sensitive measures than body temperature
and that these measures may be a direct
reflection of the inflammatory responses
in these models second the motion and
breathing rate changes are present
earlier than conventional measures here
we find that significant decreases in
body weight and body temperature are not
evident until two days or more than 48
hours after lung injury however in
contrast we were able to detect changes
in the biometrics as early as 12 to 16
hours after insult and third unlike
other metrics breathing rate which is
more physiologically relevant metric
shows this persistent elevated levels
which should more accurately reflect
changes in lung function that result
from paraquat injury to sum up a few of
the findings from the Lupus and the lung
injury studies as well as studies that I
didn't have the time to discuss today we
demonstrate how it's possible to use
fewer animals when we use more
physiologically relevant in life
measures of breathing rate for example
in the lung injury model biometrics
often detect also differences between
groups earlier in both cases here in the
course of the study than the
conventional measures in addition our
continuous monitoring ensures that
changes and environmental conditions
that may change study outcomes can be
tracked and accounted for during study
analysis there were no abnormalities in
these studies to show you as we run
additional stay
across a number of therapeutic areas we
find that many of the biometrics are
very consistent both in the time to
onset as well as in the magnitude of
change we hope that this will allow us
to begin pooling historic data to reduce
overall control numbers required in
future studies and finally by using
predictive analytics we have been able
to anticipate when an animal as at the
end of life so it can be humanely
euthanized and properly studied before
it's found dead in its cage we do all of
this while setting a new standard for
animal welfare often there's a tension
between science and animal welfare but
take this technology allows us to
increase this opportunity so that we
generate wins for both the science and
the animal welfare together as a result
during our a lack accreditation we were
given an unprecedented commendation for
promoting the 3 R's returning to the
challenges and preclinical studies we're
currently working on additional R&D
projects to explore how continuous
monitoring and biometrics can be used to
improve the reproducibility of standard
animal models and to provide insights
above and beyond the conventional
studies to improve the translational
applicability of these models in
addition we would like to begin to
investigate how biometrics and insights
can be used to create novel animal
models or in life measures that will
further enhance the drug discovery
process to that end we would love to
work with you if you're interested in
working with vayam there are two ways to
engage with us and with the technology
first we can run a study with you in our
vivarium we've run a number of studies
the areas of autoimmune disorders
inflammation organ damage and
phenotyping as well as others while
we've developed a number of models and
housed one differentiator of our
platform and our company is that we're
excited to work with anyone to run
standard or novel models on our platform
we would love to talk to you about any
models that you feel would be well
suited to the platform to make the
platform we're available to anyone we've
also created a grant program open to
both academic and private companies
submit your proposals to develop a model
on the vayam platform we'll cover all
the costs up to it
$100,000 you can visit our website to
learn more thank you for your attention
and now we'll open up for any questions
thank you for that informative
presentation dr. shadows before we get
started on the question and answer
session I like to remind our audience
how to submit your questions you can
submit questions by typing in in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as time allows
and with that let's go ahead and ask our
first question the first question asks
what other types of models have iran on
your platforms
[Music]
that question we've actually run models
across a wide variety other autoimmune
disorders that we've looked at are MS in
the inflammatory space we've looked at
far a models including both rat and
mouse models of collagen induced
arthritis we've also looked at IBD
models as well as a number of us of CNS
models including women pixi disease
we've done a few experimental models in
the area of glioblastoma as well so we
have looked at models and a fairly wide
variety of spaces and again we're
willing and interested in working in any
new areas that you feel would be most
interesting to you thank you our next
question asks yes in fact we have we do
have a TSE system in house and actually
during our early breathing rate
validation studies we did use both the
platysma graph and some of our some of
the TSE telemetry devices as means to
compare our computer vision breathing
rate metrics to these more gold standard
methods so we we do have that capability
and if there are new or novel ways that
you would like to use the telemetry
devices perhaps to look at heart rate or
blood pressure or anything else yes we
are more than capable and would be
interested in working with you on that
excellent thank you so much for that
answer it looks like we only have time
for one more question today our last
question asks how do I get access to
your system that is a great question
we understand that scientists like to be
able to explore new platforms perhaps
before they pay for them therefore we've
offered access to several of our
internal studies upon request you can go
to Viacom and register to gain access to
any of these studies in in those studies
you can explore and see all of the video
and all of the data and all of the
analytics that we've generated for those
studies so please feel free to reach out
and we'd love to give you access to some
of these studies to explore I'd also
like to thank our sponsor bio for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we do invite you to
for that announcement your colleagues
who have missed today's live event and
tell them and so then thank you for your
time and we'll see you next time here at
lab roots goodbye